so they always say you know like all the
people you've ever worked at who stands
out you know I always say Nelson Mandela
Mother Teresa I mean there's some
amazing human things but I say you know
the one that fascinating those the
person I've always told people is it's
Mike Tyson I said because I went in
there to see this man who is supposed to
be so horrific the way people describe
him to me and I know I love you I was 22
years ago and for 22 years everybody
welcome to a very special episode of
hotbox and I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike
Tyson and my dude we got an awesome
guest tonight it could be a sermon here
tonight something come to the universe
Oh interesting this is also we got Tony
Robbins Tony thank you so much for being
here you are thank you dude where do we
begin man well listen unless I've met 20
years ago and then when we first started
talking actually how did you first start
and you told me you went to the first
level the Denny over the Denny something
overnight two years ago you went
somewhere like five o'clock in the
morning so some guys in the restaurants
ain't guys what do you like to do what's
your life like when I first started
learning the skills I had a crate change
very rapidly I went to this class I
learned this stuff called neuro
linguistic programming it's how to use
language to change the programming of
the nervous system and is very powerful
you could take like somebody with a
lifetime phobia who's been in therapy
for ten years and I challenged the
therapist that's how I built my career I
got on radio and television and say
listen give me your worst patient I had
him in one hour you know tell me
somebody you've been dealing with for
years and I actually launched my career
up in Vancouver British Columbia Canada
because I was up there and I got on this
radio show and I didn't know what a
shock jock was the early day of shock
jocks way back then I'm holder right and
I got in the show and this guy just
tried to tear me up and he had this guy
call in the psychiatrist rely you're
Charlotte because I don't care what your
problem is under care how many years
you've been in therapy uncontrollable
phobia see me I'll handle it less than
one hour cuz I am the one stop therapist
baby people start calling in saying can
you do this can you that I'm like yes
yes yes of course yes and then this man
calls up and he sees a psychiatrist he
said you're a liar you're Charlotte's
and people like you should not be
allowed on the radio and I said sir
I said if you ever met me he says no so
if you ever met any of my clients
he said no she never met me never met my
clients and you're calling me a liar on
national radio I said are you a
scientist he's of course I'm a physician
I said well if you're a scientist you
must be stating you know your hypothesis
because your hypothesis is right you
don't that you don't have a clue so if
your hypothesis you just gotta test it
and I said why don't we test it I said
I'm doing a free guest event tomorrow
night at the Holiday Inn I said bring me
one of your patients give me somebody
who've never been able to cure I said
I'm sure he got plenty of those yes look
you're gonna be rough with me I can be
rough back right and long story short he
had this woman he'd been treating for
seven years with a lifetime phobia of
snakes
you know phobias uncontrollable response
to a stimulus and she dreamed the snake
would bite her on the face and her
dremen will go through and she'd wake up
three or four times a night seven years
so I said bring her down that should
take me 10 or 15 minutes right and
stirred the guy up and I used to get
like a hundred people and a free guest
event I got 500 people show up to see
the shoot out of between me and his
psychiatrist and I brought this woman
onstage and I end up wrapping a snake
around her about 20 minutes later and
she was shaking spitting when I just
mentioned snake and so that opened the
door you're not sure so I started with
you know years and years and years ago
with some of the top athletes and and
then it just grew and I worked with
Nelson Mandela and Mother Teresa and
then I started growing businesses and
now now I have 54 companies and we have
two over six billion dollars in business
in about twelve different industries and
I still my day job where I last year I
did when a hundred eight cities around
the world 18 countries this year a
little bit more than that so and the
events go for as you know now 10,000
50,000 people I know Italian
how many people you fed oh yeah I was
fed when I was 11 years old on
Thanksgiving we had no food and I never
forgot it it wasn't the food it was the
fact somebody cared so I promised myself
a time I 17 I'd feed families I've had
two then four then eight then I got to a
million then over gosh up until six
years ago I'd said about 42 million
people and then I thought you know what
if I fed I was doing this book money
mastered the game and I was interviewing
all these self-made billionaires nobody
from the lucky sperm Club we all started
from nothing and I'm interview these
guys while Congress is cutting food
stamps they call it the SNAP program now
by six point seven billion which means
every person without food in America and
there's 48 million people to go to sleep
every night 16 million or children not
knowing if they're gonna have a meal and
I was one of those kids so it's not a
statistic for me so when they eliminated
that you know it's right now it's like
every family that used to get support
has to go without food one week out of
the month 12 months a year if the
private sector doesn't make up for it so
I said what if I family beer I fed 42
million what if I fed 50 million in a
year and I said what ifs a hundred
million I said I'm gonna feed a billion
people in ten years so so far we're
gonna hit half a billion meals this year
and I'll easily hit the the billion over
the next five years and it's been one of
the one of the most beautiful things in
my life to see that what I came out of
the pain I came out of the suffering
gave me the drive to really help a lot
of people and I'm I'm gonna keep
expanding that obviously I like to get
involved on that as well that's really
cool we you know you saw it was an
impossible need sir whatever they just
came out yeah I actually have a I don't
know if you know the XPrize but Peter
Diamandis is one of my friends dear
friends and partners in business and I
said I want to feed a billion people
sustainably because what I'm doing right
now is by doing this for ten years we
should ramp up and we should be able to
provide a hundred million every year
after that of meals through feeding
America that's why I set it up but I
thought there's a billion people around
the world coming online that are
starving it's insane what can I do so I
put together a 20 million dollar XPrize
I put up the first million and then we
haven't made the official announcement
so I can't tell you but I got one other
person put up 19 million and we have 210
million dollar prizes and one of them is
you know you hear about the new green
new deal they talk about you
you know cows producing more flatulence
there methane gases more than all
airplanes and all cars combined that's
true right people are gonna stop eating
me so I said what if we did this what if
we went and did a competition where you
could eliminate right now 80% of the
land on Earth is used to feed cattle or
grow cattle if you get rid of the
IceCaps right because no one grows
anything again
that's insane crazy it's insane we're
burning down the rainforests for it it
takes this water you got that so
valuable that water for one cow from
time it's born to time its butchered is
an aircraft carrier water that they can
sell and then you have all the mad cow
disease and all the elements like that
and your depletion of the air so I said
I'm gonna create an XPrize 20 million
bucks 10 million first for somebody
comes up with a protein source where you
do not kill an animal you eliminate
eliminate eating meat yeah well no they
hear me out
they don't do it no killing of animals
80% less land use 90% less water use no
pollution here's what it is it's them so
me so it's just life yeah is this wild
they have you can do this right now you
can take the best beef in the world like
Kobe beef I'm not a beef here myself but
Kobe beef is considered I guess one of
the best you can extend cells you can
grow it now the problem is five years
ago or seven years ago was $3500 to make
a pound of this stuff so obviously
that's not working well then it got down
to 350 so now we're goal is to get in
under a buck 50 so we can feed the next
billion people we're gonna do 110
million dollar prize that's for this
this protein source but do another ten
million dollar prizes for a plant source
because people in India are never gonna
eat meat you don't want to and so we
changed the planet we see people well
meat eaters get to have the food that
they enjoy still if they want to and
those that don't want to and Facebook is
now joining us with a ten million dollar
prize that looks like for chicken and
fish so literally we'll have stem cell
that we caught it's called clean beef or
clean meat because it literally is grown
in a matter of weeks
there's no destruction in the animal
there's no pollution there's no water
usage of that nature there's no land
usage so I'm excited about it so there's
one of the projects I'm evolving how do
you eat I'm I was a vegan for 14 years
and then I had a unique experience
recently the last three years I would
start eating fish and salad and I wasn't
very disciplined and I train like a
crazy person
on these stages for you know 12 14 hours
a day 50 hours in a weekend I got ahold
10 15 50 thousand people at a time when
they won't sit for a three-hour movie so
the level of energy it takes is amazing
but what happened to me about three
years ago as I tore my rotator cuffs in
a snowboarding accident I went in to get
some PRP and then the guy says to me you
got spinal stenosis look at the spine no
more jumping no more snowboarding no
more squash egos life as you know it is
over this is his way of delivering this
communication he obviously needed some
help on his coaching communication style
but I found this doctor in Australia
that sent me videos that showed MRIs of
the spine reak regaining its strength
and literally mending itself through the
hyperbaric oxygen and so that shifted my
entire world and then when I went to go
do this here's the final part of the
story he says before you come to
Australia let's do a site a contest
let's do it you know see what kind of
inflammations in your body because if
you wait till you come here after wait a
week to get the results I'm in Newmarket
I get a test the guy says you want to do
a metals test also I said you mean like
like what type of metal see stuff you
know all the different metals I said
well I had all my amalgams out years ago
it's I couldn't have mercury anything
like that
because well there's so much metals in
the environment tests and I'm telling
everyone the story because everyone
should go do a test because oh no but
here's what happened they come back a
week later and say it's an emergency we
must you must return our call the doctor
said he saw my side he said on a scale
from zero to five or five is totally
toxic I was 123 the highest they've ever
measured he said how long you've been in
the hospital I said I'm not in the
hospital just got off stage and so the
last three years I've been detoxing that
as a result I can't have any fish and so
now I'm back to land-based protein and
vegetables and so forth and it's a
radical change from where I was before
but it's been really rough I just
actually had an experience of the day I
did 12,000 people for days and nights in
London you know you know you came to the
event in LA Mike you know it's like it's
crazy you know all day all night 12 14
hours over he's wired other minds energy
is insane it's insane and I rip it open
I did the whole thing I come home I'm
exhausted we should be exhausted but I
felt really tired I'm running with a dog
and boom I hit the ground my heart was
beating out of my chest and I measure my
heart like I I have these guys that work
with me at these events I wear this
heart monitor that's insane that use of
the greatest
athletes in the world it's like I burn
eleven thousand three hundred calories I
jump a thousand times you know you know
when you're running with somebody if you
can't speak anymore you know you're at a
four of lactate I'm in an 8 of lat
18 of lactate and still speaking so I
know my heart is incredibly strong but
what happened was I had an ulcer and it
was a little lost 1/3 of my blood supply
and I pushed through on stage not
knowing cuz I'm so crazy
and so they rushed me the hospital I
said polish it you could've died my
blood pressure went from 142 over 90 to
down to 92 over 67 so those are rough
week so I'm healing I got half the
hemoglobin I would normally have but I'm
here that's a long way of saying if
they're listening please go get a metals
test because I'd say roughly 65 to 70
percent of people that I know who got a
test end up finding there's metals and
it's better catch it early before it
starts to affect you catch it early
catching it most people feel free to go
to the doctor now just a blood test I
don't know what [ __ ] I'm so free we've
got what we did last year and - yeah
[ __ ] could send me some stuff give it
all the Mike I wouldn't have to steer it
event Mike's here and he knows you've
been taking all of his Mack welding
stuffs what what do you mean dude Evan
what do you got my ship for Evan what
are you doing my shirt then why are you
doing this it's taking my [ __ ] I know
you've been taking my shirt for a while
keep the shirts okay okay make sure this
never happens again
yes sir okay yes sir thank you so much
for 20% off your first order visit Mac
Weldon calm and her promo code Tyson for
20% off your first order
now that's Mac well done comm with promo
code Tyson for 20% off your first order
how did you guys meet Wow I come in my
house um that's him my house one day and
I'm in there I get them in the room and
I walk out in my living room and I I see
Tony Robbins I know Tony Robbins hey
what are you doing here that's what he's
doing here and I guess um my wife at the
time and some of my friends mother got
in contact and saying make me some help
Mike is [ __ ] up over here come talk to
him and I guess he came to see me right
and so your guys kidding me and said we
need to make sure he doesn't bite
somebody's here and I say he's not gonna
do it again but I'd love to meet him and
so they told me Mike's already for me
he's ready he wants to meet he's a fan
of yours gonna have a stash I said
listen I'm not here pushing myself and I
mean oh no he's right ahead coming there
might goes what the hell are you doing
my living room but you know that I've
told so many people Mike you and I
talked about this the other day but I've
told so you know the media always asked
me I've done this I'm 59 I've been doing
this since I was 17 so you have 42 years
got everything you know millions and
millions of people and so they all say
you know like all the people you've ever
worked at who stands out you know I
always say Nelson Mandela Mother Teresa
I mean there's some amazing human beings
you know Bill Clinton's a really amazing
guy and but I say you know the one that
fascinating those the person I've always
thought people this it's Mike Tyson I
said because I went in there expecting
to see this man who was supposed to be
so horrific that what people described
it to me and I fell in love with you
because you're such a Love Bug I mean
yeah first of all it's blown away by how
well-read you were I mean when you're in
a yeah the Koran and the Bible and and
then you know you know I followed up
obviously you know you know talking with
the guys at the prison they were talking
about how you ended the fights there and
I remember there was one of things that
struck me Mike that you said that first
night we were together because you were
still you know agitating cuz you're so
hurt right you know it's like you were
such a Love Bug it's like we got to do
this together he's talking about in
prison saying hey guys we can't fight
with each other the people out there hey
that's we got we don't care for each
other knows gonna care for us right now
he handed out
but then you said Mike back in those
days you but then you really sweetening
up in other days I think there's a
button there's like okay but you're real
man that's keep it real so I was getting
you ready for the next fight but it's
like it was I was there for two or three
hours it and I left telling everybody
he's one of the most well-read he's one
of the brightest guys obviously he's got
lots of parts of his personality we all
do but I said he's truly a love bug and
he's forced to beat people up and be
rewarded for it for a lifetime how
[ __ ] up is that pain to myself yes as
you saying I'm saying now I so why does
this [ __ ] Tony Robbie [ __ ] that was
22 years ago and for 22 years I've told
people the story what incredible truth
would you tell him Tony well we had long
conversations it was a bit circa the
beginning he said go work on my wife she
needs the help a phone that's gone guys
you told me he was ready for me go so we
had to kind of gradually work into it it
was really finding his world and finding
what really mattered him but I just felt
for you Mike because so many people took
advantage of me I mean [ __ ] you know you
were hypnotized into this world right
you you you grew up in the toughest
environments but he could ever dream of
and I think you navigate incredibly well
and then people don't realize the stress
doesn't just come from pain stress also
comes some success whenever you go
beyond what you think you're gonna be if
you know if the thermostat your comfort
zone of your finances of your life of
your emotion so your business is set at
68 degrees and you drop to 62 60 there's
a point the thermostat goes it's ain't
good enough I'm a 68 degree or man this
I got to do something you feel the drive
to change almost everybody's felt that
but what most people don't know is if
you think your 68 degree are mentally
emotionally spiritually whatever that
metaphor is and you start doing better
than you anticipate and you become the
greatest in the history of the world of
twenty years old people understand that
when you get to 99 100 there's a partyer
brand go
wait a second I'm a 60-degree what the
hell are you doing here and so then I
did let's start destroying yourselves
exactly right that feels good too
cuz you want to get back to where you
think you deserve to be tan right that's
what that's what you do so I saw that
pattern him back then it was an obvious
pattern and I have that pattern also
maybe not as extreme in some ways
because I didn't have to go through some
of the most extreme things you go out
there a lot of extreme things but not as
extreme as you might [ __ ] half and [ __ ]
happen well hopefully [ __ ] happens we
make use of it right yeah and don't let
it just you fall down a hundred times
you get up a hundred time you've you
learned a hundred lessons that's right
brother that's right and I just mired
the [ __ ] out of it like I've always had
a level of insane discipline and what I
loved about you is like your add your
being up at 4:00 a.m. running in the
snow and knowing your competitors
doesn't have that doesn't have that
Drive it's pretty you still have that
part of you and I just love seeing you
today being able to mellow build your
ranch build all the stuff that you've
done I mean Mike you deserve it and
people all over the world love your ass
man and they still love you I'm very all
these things and because they feel your
humility man they feel how much you've
grown
you're a role model of what's possible
man you came from some of the toughest
environments you did some crazy [ __ ] but
you've turned your life around and such
beautiful ways it some other means I'm
here because I respect them love you so
much I'm so happy that you here as well
man that election anyone in Titan ranked
11th respect you this won't you brother
thank you and no doubt about that man
[ __ ] it's really wild journey let's
never get discouraged the whole thing
not to be discouraged that's right
that's one of the most beautiful things
about Mike no matter what happens like
[ __ ] it get back up again
learns nothing owns the knife or anybody
you've done the same thing in your
cranny buddy who's ever done anything
knows that but Mike's maybe the most
example of that right I think that's why
inspires people because you can talk a
good game all day long but it's how you
live your life that matters man and you
you know the little brief interview we
did when you're at my house we sent a
little piece of that on the Instagram
and things like that and I was so
touched because people get all over
people in social media too it's just
insane but you were so beloved they just
were touched by the
the words that you share they're touched
by humility and and people love you Mike
you know 22 years ago they still loved
you and then sauce it's a gorgeous thing
yes yes life is beautiful you know and
never had time to really absorb that you
know it's really beautiful life and it's
worse it's worse it's really beautiful a
lot better than the alternative right
yeah not being here all right so true
man what you said earlier about how you
fell in love with Mike
yeah meeting him because everybody's
like he's this ferocious vicious warrior
man I know when I met him and I saw how
huge his heart is I just fell in love
with this guy yeah you know yeah what's
the most important thing that someone
can cultivate hone practice in their
life to reach their highest self I think
we all motive matters right so if you're
doing something just for yourself
there's nothing wrong with that because
you're part of life and I think life
supports life that's why we get insights
to protect ourselves or be able to do
okay but life supports whatever supports
more of life so when your focus is to
serve something more than yourself I
think finding something you care about
more than yourself I don't care if it's
your kid I don't care if it's a mission
I don't care if it's a company I don't
care what it is
finding something you do more for than
you do for yourself most people do that
for their own child that's a that's
about it but if you can find something
got nature it calls to that gives you an
energy and that energy is something you
can execute you can change the world
building change yourself whether you
change anything with it so if you're
just trying to help yourself to a
certain level of insight I remember I
love a lady and married her and she been
married twice before him he had kids
from both of these men so I was and she
was older I was she was I think 12 years
older so I was literally 24 and had a 17
year old son instantly had an 11 year
old daughter had a five year old son and
then a child on the way I mean that'll
that'll flip your brain a little bit
right and so but it was beautiful
because it made me grow in a different
way I want to serve humanity but I also
want to serve my family and it just I
had to come up with a different level of
set of insights to do that so I think
number one is find something to serve an
englis
you know I think was Martin Luther King
is this a man who hasn't found something
he's willing to die for isn't fit to
live it's pretty strong words but I
think you certainly won't feel alive
until you find that and so I try to help
people to find that within themselves
but the other part to me is just
realizing life's not just about me it's
about we the secret livings giving I
Mike's a giver you know I haven't I
don't know you haven't met you before
but I can just feel your energy about it
like you're here to contribute you're
not here to take I mean I came here to
tell you to hopefully give I'm hoping
some of the people listening between the
three of us will be some conversational
stimuli maybe there'll be something
about their help maybe or something
about their finances maybe something
bout their family but I want to be at my
daily wish is to be a blessing in life
anybody I mean sometimes I can do that
just like you might because somebody
meets you and just just meeting your
lights them up right cos you know they
perceive you a certain way or they've
been touched by you in the past I have
that experience sometimes it's digging
in and saving somebody's life is
suicidal you know it's like I I deal
with the realm
people come to me at extremes they come
to me because they're the best in the
world they're looking for that edge
that's how they stay the best they come
to me when they're in a tough spot when
they've you know been the best and
there's a challenge that's like how we
got hooked up or somebody got you know
changing the life of a birthday with a
zero on it you know or they got a
divorce or they're starting a new
business who my market is is people that
are hungry if you're hungry to grow then
I you're my market if you're that
lukewarm middle I'm not for you because
I'm too passionate too intense and too
crazy and you don't need this [ __ ] for
us to hang out with me but if you're
looking to have an edge and the body the
mind the emotions relationships the
finances or your business the areas that
matter I've spent 42 years studying the
best on earth and it's not my insights
it's I believe in modeling I believe
success leaves clues that if someone is
the best on earth it's something they're
not effing lucky and you know somebody
goes lose weight and get it back
somebody's lost weight and kept it off
for 20 years somebody's fallen in love
and they're still passionately you know
in a relationship
20 years later so any of those things
somebody started with nothing and 20
years later you didn't get rich can you
stay wealthy
that's a different game and those the
people I want to find out what makes
them cuz listen I'm no dummy I mean most
people are not fit and healthy in
America most people do not have great
relationships most people are not
earning what they deserve or what they
want most people are not really that
happy
but a few are and I'm it's in the few do
versus than many talk and I'm interested
in finding out what they do and teaching
it to people said they can change their
life
awesome I heard somebody say you called
Mike the ultimate Redeemer is that
reused some language like that yes I
think he's just I just think he's the
ultimate role model of what's possible
for people I mean the other thing I hate
is that today so many people want to
hold somebody in place for some the way
they talked or spoke or did something 20
or 30 or 40 years ago or whatever the
number is that it's so absurd we all
were idiots at times and we grew yeah
right and that's the definition of a man
or a woman is not what they did or what
they were it's who they are and it's how
they deliver that's how they live and as
how they treat people and so you look at
Mike and he's the perfect example of the
extreme of one side to the extreme of
the other now that's why I think he's
such an inspiration well you're getting
a lot of credit here today one phone to
pick you stole my logo here for your RAM
yeah this is my logo on my plane dude
bison ranch Tony Robbins dude it's cool
you and Mike have something in common
you thought what's this you've both had
a pretty impactful experience with the
toad yes we have and I would be like the
last person consider it I tell you how
it happened for me is I feel like you
know no matter what somebody has to deal
with no like I'm so brilliant but Ivan
knew this 42 years and they're only so
many patterns so I get the call when you
know the athletes burning down on
national television and I got to do
something right now and there's no net
everybody's paying attention right so
like the old days you know it sees
Serena Williams and her sister you know
got killed and get I got to turn her out
now you know or I get the phone call
when the child is suicidal and you know
knock on wood I've never lost one
suicide out of thousands and 42 years
and we have films and some people
listening may have seen there's a
Netflix documentary called Tony Robbins
I'm not your guru yeah yeah
you can see where I won't deal with
these suicides one after now there are
all kinds of people but suicides are the
most extreme and so I've learned how to
do that and learn how to produce the
result make it last I get the phone call
in the present itíd States calls me true
story and says they're gonna teach me in
the morning what should i do not Trump
right this is Clinton back in those days
but he says you're gonna beat me in the
morning what should I do and I'm like 31
years old and I'm like dude could you
call me sooner it's morning right but
because I had to do that I had to
constantly look for patterns and once I
realize we are not our patterns like
whatever you do like were the only
creatures in the plan that can make
herself angry with a single thought we
can then have a different thought and be
grateful I've didn't thought the Excite
ever didn't thought be pissed off right
and so I really became fascinated in
patterns but the one pattern that I felt
impotent in was helping somebody when
they're dying and the reason is because
frankly I think what drove me to be so
successful in squeeze every moment out
of my life was that I don't want to die
here not only everybody wants to die but
I think early on in my life I had this
fear of death and I want to maximize the
time I was here and so that push drove
me but it made me not really know what
do I do with somebody who's told they
got terminal cancer it just crushes me
because I love people I hate seeing
people in pain my whole life is about
ending suffering for people and that one
area I didn't know what to do so I met
this doctor Grob from UCLA and then I
met Tony Bossi's from NYU's medical
school and they've been doing this
research on cancer patients and they do
veterans and a series of others but the
one that grabbed me the most was
terminal cancer patients where they were
using at that time mushrooms so Simon
and Tony bosses by the ways a beautiful
man and I've become good friends with
him and he was saying Tony let me show
you these videos and he would show me
and it's a double-blind study and you
know they put a mask on somebody and
they give him this medical level so
Simon or they give him you know
obviously a sugar pill and he said these
people have a one-time experience and
their life is completely altered he said
when you think of drugs most people
think of drugs something you got to keep
taking over and over again he said this
is a one-time experience that
permanently changes people will they no
longer have a fear of death I was like I
want to see this because he showed me
this video this woman he goes now before
I show this this woman sounds hard she
goes she's told me up front
you'll see in the video that she said
she's not just an atheist she's in New
York
atheist not a California theist where
there might be some nice rainbows and
[ __ ] like that a New York atheist there
is nothing he showed me the video of her
pants and she's got terminal cancer and
he shows me after she's had this
experience of three and a half hours you
know with and that's that case it was so
Simon and the woman has complete
transform she has experienced God she
knows there's God she has no fear of
death her whole family's transformed so
I've actually actually helped to fund
some studies and I'm actually now
working with him to see if we can raise
money I'm gonna be a part of that
process to bring a series on a mom a
priest and a rabbi and a group of
different religious leaders to have this
experience so they can share what they
experience through their language to
people in that area but I'm interested
in veterans that I managed in and the
Deaf experience so I went down to Brazil
and I had an experience there with
ayahuasca in the Amazon which was wild
shed tense very intense but as intense
as that was and I'd done all the
research on it and the thing that was
interesting to me is and all these
people that are depressed take these
SSRIs you know this Prozac and all this
crap
it's like 15% of the population takes
something of that nature in the US it's
insane but they're not you know I know
people and I'm sure you do that take
multiple SSRIs and they're still
depressed they take an impressive still
depressed horrible cuz they haven't
changed what's going on inside so I go
to change what's going on inside but I
want I heard about and I started reading
about the pain receptors and the
dopamine receptors being changed by
ayahuasca like increasing it so that joy
could rent a know someone so I said I
want to experience of it so when to
Brazil it's legal there and had the
experience but then this little
character tell about your experience of
the day and then I'll talk about mine
okay so listen I'm on um five the toads
I'm Jelena Park kids I'm talking to
somebody he's talking to me about this
medicine and I'm listening and I said
let me try this where is it at and so I
have someone let me try it he said
wasn't after the show you can try it so
I'm listening
if I can to tell me this is good this is
magical and this is you know this is a
guard monocle and listen you ever hear
but the toll
and so we go in there we smoked the pipe
we sit down on the floor on a matches of
smoke it and it hits a bone
I'm going I don't know where I'm in
another dimension yeah I am gonna have
no body I have nothing I you've had my
energy you don't exist but you do I'm
getting a thousand years of information
within 15 minutes
Amanda how fast is coming to me I have
to be glorious crisis was so life and
the glories of death for me worried
[Music]
thousand years just coming at you just
fast everything and I said I'm dead I
[ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I guess um I was
trying to prove something that I could
handle this drug and it killed me I
[ __ ] up and so um I was just dead
everything I ever loved my children my
wife my family anything I loved my
friends they didn't exist I never
thought about them never mentioned them
and there's never existence one world
anymore
I had nothing but me what happened
excuse me huh and what happened and that
in that particular situation I just woke
up and I think you shouldn't use that
when you stop using okay yeah I stopped
using just stop drinking stopping that
anyone do the enema so I did this I took
another head of the toad yes what
happened second time um second time was
um it was smooth yeah because I did
recently - yes I did it all together I
must have did it five times
Wow oh [ __ ] yeah over a period of time
yelu period time yeah and what do you
think is the biggest impact it's out on
you you just attack your consciousness
it does you don't want to do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you very where this is gonna put me
in the wrong direction I don't want to
go that direction you don't want to
improve yourself and and you want to
understand yourself you want to
understand this and I think in life
people didn't ever getting living their
life they never get a chance to
understand who they are and what they
are I think is a wasted life
not half self-aware I mean one of the
beautiful things about you Mike again
you're getting all these comments but
it's true they're sincere is your
self-awareness right your your ability
to see who you were and your ability to
step out of that I mean choose who you
wanted to become and a lot of people
have a hard time doing that my
experience the funny I would say they
told me dance they go this is very
intense stuff which again immediately
pulled me in right I don't use drugs if
any sort I never have I been
honestly I don't drink I don't smoke I'm
prude is just what made you and well
because my family my mother who's
probably the one influenced not probably
influenced me the most I love her dearly
and huge influence in my life but she
used prescription drugs and alcohol
abuse them both and she was crazy would
beat my head against the wall by blood
soaked down my throat till I threw up
seeing I was lying and I wasn't and I'm
not and I'm not being dragged to her
torture she's past I didn't talk about
the stuff she passed even then and talk
about toes with a group of kids that
were all abused and I was trying to tell
them your past is an equi future you're
bog if he doesn't define you brother and
sisters but you know they look at this
tall white guy that's you know wealthy
now financially and thinking oh yeah
easy for him so I thought [ __ ] it I told
him the whole story as first time I ever
told anybody and they're all crying
their eyes out at the end but what I
want you to know is out of all that [ __ ]
it made me a practical psychologist it
made me want understand what makes
people do what they do and made me want
to have no one suffer but I in the area
of death like I said I suffered even
thinking about it and I suffered that
couldn't help anybody so I did the
ayahuasca and then they said now we have
this toad thing I said what the [ __ ] is
that you know five MgO and like tell me
about it it goes of a god molecule or
stuff like like what are the side
effects and outside but nothing has no
side effects don't give me this [ __ ]
right and so finally I was there I spent
the day reading everything I could about
it and I finally said you know what the
ayahuasca was a great experience but I
still didn't feel I could transform my
death experience for me and so I did it
and so they've told me advanced ago
you're so big you know you're six seven
to 80 we need like four or five guys to
hold your dad we're gonna tie you down
your tie me down with a maybe because we
don't want you scratching your eyes
Junior you could get crazy in this I
said how long is this last cycle 1012
minutes so they give me this stuff and
nothing happened so they gave me a ton
because I'm big right they gave me a ton
is like that's they told me that should
be enough to take out an elephant I'm
like well [ __ ] I don't feel anything
this is [ __ ] right nothing happened
nothing so the next day they said we're
gonna try it again and I guess they
really loaded me up and I went out but
but I I had at that point I had two
problems in my throat and I was having
sleep apnea and so as I went out I
couldn't breathe and I was screaming I
can't breathe I thought like I was dying
and I kept
and they couldn't control me I was
running all the place they tied me down
I ripped out of the tie there it was
crazy in this ten minutes was two
[ __ ] hours [ __ ] cuz the amount they
gave me what the [ __ ] but here the first
hour was how and if you'd see me you'd
think it was insane and you know I guess
my eyes are open but I couldn't see
anybody or see anything and then the
last hour was one of the most beautiful
experiences in my life which is what
Tony bosses had kind of alluded to
before it's like I felt the direct
connection to all that is I felt that
our connection to spirit to soul to my
own soul I hadn't this conversation with
myself that I'll never forget from a
higher self to me I felt the presence of
God my wife was with me and I looked in
her look like if I died this she was the
greatest gift that ever happened to me I
already felt that but it was even deeper
I felt so much gratitude I mean I came
out of the experience with a
transformation like you did only the
only difference is for the next ten days
I was because I guess the amount that
gave me I woke up every morning and had
this euphoric experience but you forward
but it was like making sounds like
yelling sounds to get the vibration out
of my body and it would go on for like
30 minutes of like ecstatic feelings but
soaps that you know if you smile so much
face hurts it was like this [ __ ] needs
to stop and then like I I done this down
there and come up from Brazil and
normally like every you know every three
or four days I'm gonna summer her said
this one ten day period and the ten days
were up and I had to get on stage in
Vegas and a crowd of 12,000 people and
I'm half of this experience right in the
morning before it starts I'm like holy
[ __ ] and my brain just overrode it and I
got onstage and I delivered and I never
had that experience again but literally
I had ten days in a row of this euphoric
experience in my whole nervous system
gonna be wired and so I have no fear of
death no mercy if you're a death I don't
want to die but I've no fear of death
and more importantly now I can really
help people in that environment it's
transform me in that area because cuz
you can't get someone to feel what you
don't feel you can't touch other people
if you've not been touched
you can't move other people if you've
not been moved and so I had a direct
experience because I I wouldn't that all
about the ship with the you know I
didn't want to be a part of it cuz you
know my background everybody around
was abusing drugs and alcohol and they
were abusive so I never want to touch
this [ __ ] but in this case it's like I
always tell people you know a belief is
a poor substitute for an experience you
can believe all you want with something
else and one other person um dr. Sanjay
Gupta I really I want to acknowledge him
I love him he's a beautiful manual from
CNN medical doctor and neurosurgeon and
he was about as straight-laced about
this [ __ ] as I am and like on marijuana
and he thought it was horrible and you
know he started doing studies and
researching started tell me about the
research about like kids that you know
you're having you know brain aneurysms
and things of that nature
yeah brain seizures rather and how what
an unbelievable gifted wasn't now as I'm
sure you've seen he's a supporter of the
Affleck so the world's changing and I
think we reacted to the abusive things
but what I liked about these experiences
is I can do it one time and have my life
be altered I don't have to do it it's
not something I gotta go do daily to
bring myself back to that state have
access to those states within me because
I lock them in in there and they're
valuable and they they they give me
great gifts so the tone is blessed this
both my friend are big time same time
one time I took the Thole family and I
felt the pain of everybody that ever oh
wow yeah that's wild and did you let it
go afterwards yeah let it go but one
crib I thought the oneness of oneness is
what that experience most what the rock
whatever our air is everything you ever
you I feel every drug everything
anything drink or whatever it took for
anything it's just crazy
you just think about how people are so
separated today you're looking socially
disenfranchised crazy
yeah we have one saw the statistical
today one out of every well first of all
since 1990 was in 1992 to 2014 so what
12 years the use of an oppressor
increased in America by 65 percent and
suicides exploded during that time even
more so this is on side of the packaging
and mostly accessorize you know you can
create suicidal thoughts oh I was
depressed now I'm suicidal a really
really great thing it's just crazy the
way we have a drug culture and yet we
don't look at some of these natural
remedies like what honey bosses doctor
Bastas was telling me from NYU's medical
schools they sing Tony
there's receptors in your brain that are
tied to these mushrooms the mushrooms
have been around as long as humanity is
and those receptors have this specific
impact on anybody who takes it he goes
that's not just random yeah right
there's something here but we reacted in
the 1970s the Nixon year some people are
just partying and using [ __ ] to party it
wasn't any form of consciousness and so
we've created and put people in prison
over those stupid things that people
just trying to change their state and
they don't know a better way than using
a drug and for people trying to you know
trying to be part of it it said you know
we're talking about these breakthroughs
I'm actually doing a book right now
on life force and that's all the
regenerative medicine but the thing I
wanted to mention for anybody listening
as I care so much about you know you got
so many vets coming back that have gone
to so many tours of duty it's insane
their lives are destroyed with PTSD and
I know how to deal with it I've turned
around but I'm not scalable as over so
many hours I can put in with you know a
small number of people but there is a
doctor named dr. lip often in Chicago
that I just recently met he has found a
way to wipe out I know it sounds insane
but it's a fact PTSD with two shots in
one session
92% successful he's in anesthesiology
what's his name again
dr. lipof ly POV I'll get you the
contact so that anybody watching is
interested kinda I'm not a sponsor I'm
paying it's it's you know most people
know that your nervous system has a
sympathetic and a parasympathetic
sympathetic as you know is go-go-go
and most of us have been go-go-go most
of our lives you found parasympathetic I
think through some of your approaches
but what it does is an anesthesiologist
he knows two places that interrupts the
pattern of being that accelerator being
stuck which makes like the first guy I
ever worked with he told me was a man
who was they took him away cuz he's
gonna kill his wife and he wasn't trying
to kill his wife he was just in the
experience of being back in Iraq all
over again and he was strangling her and
to try to survive and he came in and did
he wanted to kill himself obviously
because he didn't want to kill his wife
you want to kill himself to get out of
this horrible situation it was
personally worked with and he did this
one shot in this one location and it
didn't work he needed a second one after
two
we found the right combination and the
man is totally healthy and fine today
has no reactions they still have the
memories but there's no emotion to the
memories the amygdala the part of the
brain that makes us react with
incredibly intense emotions it blocks
that pattern around this experience so
I'm sponsoring a hundred vets and I'm
sponsoring thirty women who've been then
through sexual rape and abuse I I'm part
of Underground Railroad on if you guys
heard about it but it's all before oh
they're great group of guys former CIA
former FBI former SEAL Team six guys
that have all banded together to go
Underground Railroad to free young girls
and boys around the world but what they
do is they go in and they drop the guys
actually I can't tell you where because
then look at the flashback come on me I
had full movie make I've had scars all
my face the whole thing and I went
through a three-day process where we
trapped 37 of these perpetrators and the
girls we freed there were 42 girls we
freed and they were from the ages of 7
to 14 chained to a bed being given
heroin and cocaine mostly cocaine so
they'd have sex with these men it's the
most gross thing I've ever seen in my
life but the most beautiful thing was
seeing him free but then the problem is
they're free but there's all the
tortilla inside so I'm gonna I'm
sponsoring that group as well and I want
to try and help get this guys work out
it's already been duplicated in the Army
in several different locations Fort Hood
is one of them but he wants to take this
to a larger scale so I just thought as
long as we're talking about these kinds
of breakthroughs yeah if somebody knows
somebody about that they I should look
up dr. lipof and I'll get you the
contact info so if they go to your
website or so yeah that they could find
out more about it but it's a one-time
session 92% it's totally pretty good the
trauma to the throat is - that's true
but I don't know I don't know if the
total be the right thing for everybody
and of that who's already kind of in a
wild state but this also what's nice is
it's it's medical it's done you know
bananas these see theologists they know
what they're doing and just want people
know that there's an answer out there
because there are men and women that are
tortured 22 I think the numbers 22
veterans a day take their own lifestyle
yeah it's insane we have a lot to change
but look in this country there's been a
big change around marijuana obviously
human being
yes human being thing
we like who we are why we have to why we
want to change our state I think it's
because you know we are living a social
culture and people are constantly making
comparisons and I think the mental
health has been challenging I'm sure
you've seen the recent studies there was
a 20-19 study by Gallup saying it's one
of the angriest most unhappy times in
most countries of the world that we've
ever had you see these great athletes in
the NBA you know the one the NBA
commissioner was talking about and some
friends of mine or team owners were
telling me about it saying these guys
are the most unhappy they've ever seen
for two reasons number one they all live
in their own world they got their
headsets on you know it used to be like
Jordan used to say you build
championship teams on the plane between
cities you know you looks like there's a
there's a camaraderie but everybody's
got their own world not everybody but
many and you know and then in addition
there's all the social medias that guy
makes a mistake and people just burn
them over and over and over again and so
these guys are living a lonely life and
what a life were like you look at like
like a guy like Harden you know or
LeBron these guys are some of the
greatest athletes or you know you look
at the war here so if you can name a
number of members of the Warriors right
and they really take so much crap today
it's such a different world and so it's
hard for them to be able to find a
balance but I think what it is is we're
all making comparisons all the time and
our culture's been more significance
driven anything would be significant
significant you bad or significally good
something significant and the problem
was significant some yours main
comparisons you can never find you and I
think what people really want is love
and you told me something Mike that I'll
never forget
yeah when we met 22 years ago in your
house there and we were in your training
2000 Arizona and I remember I somehow I
got on the subject of the white black
and thing and how people treat each
other and you're telling me about the
Sally Jessy Raphael show that you saw
with this white supremacist then he's
got this you know shaved head and he had
it across his chest f you know the
n-word and I was asking what do you
think is wrong with her why do you think
you do that and you were so brilliant
you said you know he wants power cuz he
doesn't have love and I was like holy
[ __ ] man it's like this guy's so
brilliant and I think people really want
love but our culture is promoting
significance behind me people one of my
buddies owns a gym and he was telling me
least twice sometimes three times a week
people come in lay out the whole workout
take all these pictures then they don't
work out they said it that there's a new
company I just saw that you can put your
picture in and it makes it look like you
went on vacation these fancy places I
mean I read started a millennial say
they believe that the most stressed out
you know a generation ever I saw this
thing today a headline saying more young
people are having dying of heart failure
than ever before I'm right you know
leave but when you don't when you it's
like a child never breaks a bone if you
never left the child you protect the
child they never fall down they live in
fear their whole life but somebody who's
jumped off a building or down a few
crazy things have broken her bones and
healed them like you don't have any fear
because you know hey I'm gonna heal
right so we've got not everybody but
we've because of Technology it's
nobody's fault
and because a lot of parents raise their
kids where they micromanage everything
for them that now they want they want
that to be the way the rest of the world
is if the world's got to match their
view and I say look what's beauty about
life is diversity you want see God love
you wants you the universe loves
whatever you believe go to the forest
everything is different every twig
there's similarities but everything's
different but this idea that we're all
supposed to think the same way be the
same way agree on everything it's like
what makes me so upset as you see people
making enemies at the other side I
remember when I worked I worked on both
sides of the aisle politically to help
people on both sides you know
Republicans and Democrats obviously I'm
independent myself um but I remember in
the days when I worked I knew Reagan if
I got a chance to see him you know get
Tim know briefly but those days they
would go and the opposite sides what's
his name the guy from Boston who is this
archrival in the Democrats the guys
would fight on the House floor like
crazy and then they'd go have a beer and
laughing and be friends now if you talk
to this side you're evil that's why
nothing gets done today we gotta stop
this demonization we've got to start to
remember all brothers and sisters that
yes
everybody's been hurt everybody's had
injustice in their life and everybody's
made mistakes but the secret is what
what can we do now how do we move the
ball forward instead of living in the
past because the past doesn't equal the
future unless you live there if you try
to drive in a future using a rearview
mirror you
crash I think it's like we got to create
the new future and I think people are
getting sick of it people are getting
tired of the extremes on both sides in
the political environment regardless of
what you're where you are in the
political environment so much it's crazy
it's got to change and so I think the
pendulum is thrown so far I think
eventually it's got a balance out at the
goodwill it's such an interesting
dynamic of as we get more comfortable
more comfort to take care of yes we get
more sensitive that's right yet we get
more extreme in our views and with
[ __ ] bizarre what's mostly bizarre is
I want I want everyone to believe what I
believe right yeah I want you to have
the ability to say whatever you want
think whatever you want but as long as
it aligns with me I mean it's it's been
done by both right and left extremes
it's not we live in such a big manic
whirl of fear and look and everybody's
medicating - that's the other yeah you
know you see though one out of six
Americans is using some psychotropic
drug right now to medicate themselves
one out of three you're using something
that relates to their antianxiety after
depression something that nature that
statistic blows my mind how many of you
be cocaine I don't know it well I know
this we're 4% of the world's population
in America we use 80% of the world's
cocaine there's some there's some we
spend more money on alcohol than we do
on education we wonder well we got a
problem right don't you think it's the
exact thing that you help people with
it's because nobody in this [ __ ]
country feels like they have a purpose
or they are aligned with their true self
and who they are I think lots of people
do I don't think it's nobody I think a
lots of people do but I think what
happens is there's a small number of
people
it's like weapons you used to like if
you and I are gonna have a conflict
you're a big son of a [ __ ] I'm too we'd
go at it but there'd be a price to pay
so we think it through right you know is
it really worth it but now you can burn
somebody online or you can attack
somebody without with immunity and so
there's no consequence for things
anymore and so there's no balance but I
think what's really truly happening is a
small number of people just like weapons
now now somebody can blow up an entire
city with one little
now with social media small number of
people or in a university a small number
of people can kind of dominate because
of the use of social media and I think
we're gonna find our balance we have to
because worse we're humans and we need
each other and we're brothers and
sisters on the path and the more divided
we are the more unhappy we are we have
to unify and doesn't mean we all have to
agree by any stretch but we gotta unify
the point of saying hey you can appoint
feels like it's like guns everybody
whatever the other side is whether you
believe in guns are not the other side's
evil that's the way they operate they're
taking away my guns through evil oh they
have guns they're evil how about what do
we all agree on we all want our kids
protected we all want our schools
protect we all want our churches
protected that's where we should be
putting our focus instead of how evil
you are cuz you have a different
solution than I do yeah whatever that
solution is we'll get there what's your
thoughts on where we come from if we're
all we're all for others who are we I
think we're soul I think we're spirit I
think I've had some experience I think
well I think our everyone has a unique
own purpose and I think it some people
try to make it so big when you know one
purpose isn't more important than
another it's like I'm I'm driven to try
to help you know tens of millions of
people I've been able to do that but I
gotta help myself first you know and I
still do but at the same time you know
if I help save one person's life bring
one person's life there that should be
enough now for my model the world it's
not but I know it's enough
intellectually you know my wife is
better at like gosh we just helped one
person she's like honey we don't have to
go travel all over the earth as much
time anything else um I guess we do I
got to do this this is what I'm made for
and she respects that but you know I
watch her and she's brilliant with
people one on one I'm good with people
one on one but she can do something one
I want to be totally fulfilled by it so
some people the fulfillment is writing a
poem some people are raising a beautiful
child for some people it's having a
gorgeous garden some people try to be a
song for some people it's like bringing
a new level of education for some people
it's bringing you know new answers in
the medical field we all have something
to deliver but people have to find what
that is and it doesn't have to be giant
it just has to be fulfilling mmm that's
what giant most people are not fulfilled
when you look around and you see I
always tell people there's two skills
you got a master to have life on your
terms and to me an extraordinary life I
extraordinary quality of life is life on
your terms not how I think it should be
right so what would that look like for
you and what get you there is two skills
one is mastering the science of
achievement like you've done that you've
done that I've done that like how do you
take your dreams and make them real most
people just have story in their head but
they never make it real learning how to
do that in multiple areas business
finance emotions relationships spirit
whatever that's a skill but it's a
science because you can learn from other
people I you know I wrote a book called
money masters the game I interviewed 50
the smartest financial people in the
world Ray Dalio Carl Icahn Warren
Buffett right and found out what they
did in common I applied that and took my
little 50 hundred million of our
companies and turned in a billion dollar
companies because I just modeled what
they did it's a science but the thing
that matters most in life Mike and I I
think Evan is that most of society
misses is the more important skills the
art of fulfillment like if you succeeds
to seek succeed you're always going for
the next thing you're uh you're on that
you're on that roller coaster you're on
that treadmill right you know like
they're out on the treadmill and it you
gotta find what fulfills you we're
talking I'll ask on yeah that what
happens what do you see what happens so
bad the so painful we said oh no I can't
take there's no [ __ ] no bow yeah when
people think that living is more painful
than dying that's when they try to take
their life and knock on wood reason I've
never lost anybody is I know how to
shift that I have to do it differently
with every person because it'll take
something different everyone is unique
but if you get somebody where they think
dying would be much more painful than
living they're not gonna take their life
you know they gotta do something
different
what's your weigh in on that yeah it's
different every time I got a dig I got
to understand the person cuz everybody
has a different model the world like
some people's expectations their belief
systems our life should be taking care
of me I got to show people that life is
calling to you you need to deliver
something to life because as long as
you're waiting for somebody to take care
of you then you're always the victim
you're always waiting whereas if you
think that I'm here to deliver something
to life I have a responsibility life to
give something I just get something
that's when people feel alive because
what you get never makes you happy right
I said people what's the greatest thing
you've ever done greatest achievement
and then how long we happy after that
five years a year six months among three
weeks three [ __ ] hours how long right
and it's somewhere between three [ __ ]
hours and three months and most
cases right now much longer than that
I'm saying because we got to keep
growing it's not about getting the goal
yeah it's about who you become and
pursuit of it what you get doesn't make
you happy who you become makes you
really happy or it makes you really sad
and the beauty of you mike is who used
to come I mean that's what's [ __ ]
inspiring I think yeah thank you thank
you
[ __ ] I had a good everything meant to
and he's never believed in giving up yes
viable things in life no yeah that that
part of your training and conditioning
is the most valuable one cuz it got you
to here brother it got you through all
the [ __ ] cuz you just wouldn't give up
and I understand that completely I
wouldn't be here you really my whole
story it sounds really cool yeah he's
got 54 companies that are the and you
know mr. positive and [ __ ] like that but
if you saw that the journey I went on
you know you would be like holy [ __ ]
some day I'll write a biography when I'm
older people's minds will be blown
because they just have no clue what I've
gone through to be here but that's why I
can deliver because I've been through
the stuff you haven't been through it
it's it's just a concept they even
through it you have the experience to
help people is there anything that you
want to hit it hit before we get out of
here man I would just say to people I
don't know what else we covered just so
you have to begin to contact with you oh
they can go to my website Tony Robbins
calm or they go on Instagram or Facebook
or ever they like but I just say that I
hope the people listening will really
consider one thing how many people do
you know they had everything and they
were miserable or even took their life
and so you got to find what's gonna
fulfill you but what's gonna fulfill you
is not the same for every person that's
what's unique about so I call it the art
not the science and science achievement
artists of film it if you don't find
what fulfills you man it's like you
won't be Oh making a difference for
anybody else that's like you when you
got on a plane and the first thing they
tell you and again an airplane is how to
use your seatbelts if you don't know
that [ __ ] after 20 or 30 40 50 years and
then they say if there's a problem this
oxygen gonna pull out of the ceiling and
these masks and where they tell you the
minute it comes in immediately put it on
your child right and then what they tell
them nice a put it on yourself ya know
it sounds so freakin selfish why would
you put are you bastard you're trying
but it's cuz if you don't take care
yourself you can take care of your child
and so what I found and it's been a new
lesson for me I was a super achiever I
still not achieve but now I'm much more
interested in the fulfillment of life
I'm much more interested in savoring the
moments you know I'm much more
interested in finding what gives me
juice because the more fulfilled I am
the more I can give the more I can
deliver because I'm fulfilled I got that
oxygen in me and I think you got to find
that and the only way you find that is
you got to draw a line in the sand and
stop the suffering and most of us don't
think of us as suffering like I'm an
achiever we didn't get fearful right we
just get stressed yeah stress is the G
word for fear but I found that unless I
really consciously break the pattern the
human mind is amazing it's always you
know we got a to mineral brain in here
and it's always looking for what's wrong
so you can fight it or you can fight it
or you can freeze you know to hopefully
be left alone but there's no
saber-toothed tiger anymore so now
people go life-and-death about what
people think about them or they get life
and death about money when you know if
you live in America and you're in total
poverty you're in the top 1% of 100 top
10% of earners on the planet it's just
crazy
you know most people living 2 dollars
and 50 cents a day around the world so
we have lost track of that so my
encouragement if you're listening if you
have any interest in what the hell I'm
saying is why don't just achieve but
really take some time to figure out one
of the things they're gonna fulfill you
and the ones you love and make sure you
carve out time for that because it'll
give you energy for all the other things
that you want to deliver or achieve or
create or give to the world and I think
I hope people do that and I hope people
remember the beginning this conversation
and get a blood test and check out your
medals because you can handle it when
it's early you don't want to wait until
it gets bad get your blood checked Thank
You Man Tony I gotta say man out of
everything that you do my favorite part
watching you come in here as you say hi
to [ __ ] everybody and you look them
in the eye
and you shake their hand and you ask him
how they're doing it's like dude nobody
does that I love people it's not it's
not
that's yeah but people take that for
granted in this day and age of this yeah
no I agree you know and that [ __ ] gives
you juice
does give you up and feel someone's
energy yeah without a doubt
I want to I want to make a difference
yeah and it sounds corny as [ __ ] that I
do I just synthetic I want to be a
blessing and then there's sometimes that
blessing is just a smile or a connection
or really acknowledging someone and they
feel you really with them instead of oh
hi and living on yeah on sometimes
that's saving a life sometimes that's
giving them a skill but what else you
gonna do with your damn life right you
gotta do something like absolute
something that make sure I feel like
it's meaningful yeah yeah well we got a
gift for you brother oh wow this is
gonna be so money don't break it Wow
awesome Greg Williams original photo
sign that's awesome haha I love it with
you birds do that beautiful brother
thank you so much that's gorgeous
oh that's really awesome thank you
though that's gorgeous
I really appreciate it anyway thank you
guys thank you so much all right Mike
Austin is another awesome episode of hot
box and thank you very much Tony Robbins
I'm Mike Tyson other than britain saying
good night show he hates blessings
[Music]